[Music]
it got caught news
submitted by love from San Jose a woman
dubbed her husband after she recognized
the view from her bedroom window on
another woman's Instagram page oh like a
cheater so much is this like it's a lot
of work is this between Boehner's father
like because I feel like the bedroom
window has to have such a unique view
where you're like aha that's mine show
you what it's like a [ __ ] tree I'd
like a view of the city I don't know if
they're ballers or not but she
recognized this view from her bedroom
window that's all I can I serve you
that's a really nice view and it
neighbor's house no cuz then she went on
this woman so the way the story starts
any clues huh yulia yulia oh my gosh is
the russian russian yeah why aren't more
women detectives I'm pretty sure because
well in the wall the movies don't
display it right then cuz all the
detectives and like all the all the
male's have to have the role that's yeah
because in reality I think girls make
the best [ __ ] detectives they're
really good with their nose edges they
have good intuition cuz they're all
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah nosy [ __ ] yes
see they're good with intuition they
don't even have to prove the case they
know you're lying
yeah and then return the truth Caroline
yep they'll make you believe you
committed a crime even though you did it
I didn't realize that very much like
some weird habits like I could tell what
she's like irritated by something but
it's that little suspicion thing that
gets me in trouble sometimes so for me
I'm a very very very faithful man I'm
faithful to the [ __ ] max United mean
so I was at the gym and then me and
cliff were having a conversation in the
sauna and there's literally a girl with
earbuds on and she's like this is
in the sauna right Coco dancing gyrating
her hips like hurt if you guys yeah in
front of us and I'm literally try have a
conversation with Khalid right coconuts
on a date a missile you know you think
she was trying to show off the noise she
was just working out but that was in the
sonic dancing I literally want to walk
up through like this you know and so
like I told telling Mary all that story
right because it was weird I said what
the [ __ ] is this girl doing but I think
what she heard was while you're watching
the girl dance in the soda she was like
because what she said was I was like
dude I wanted to tell her the [ __ ]
weird story like this girl was [ __ ]
gyrating also had to talk to Khalif and
I wasn't supposed to be funny she was
like well why are you telling me the
story when you're watching a girl dance
like why do girls do that it's like if I
was gonna be unfaithful or a wandering
eyes yeah why would I even tell you this
story yeah I'm telling the story because
it was innocent
exactly nosy [ __ ] syndrome kicks in oh
so you were checking her out that's what
I think it was I mean it was she didn't
admit but you could tell the tone in the
way I said that was like why are you
looking at women yeah I was like I know
that feeling I was saying that she was
kind of weird you know me but what she
heard was I was watching a girl thrust
her hips that just shows that she loves
you know I think how that makes sense
I'm a girl yeah but you do it to try to
make it sense for him
it might stem from like a insecurities
she's it all stems from insecurity oh
yeah well she shouldn't be though she's
way out of my league come on now
Oh God she had weird insecurities I just
recently cut my hair yeah you look good
thank you my mom made fun of me that's
why I cut it no the last straw if your
mom called you a [ __ ] loser that's
like oh [ __ ] well anyways back to the
story so Yulia was saying that she was
just scrolling through Instagram account
one day
she this photo puffed up of the bedroom
window because she realized that the
woman who posted it her name is Lada so
Vlada yeah is this book at a Russian
community in Russia called Moscow Moscow
oh okay
yeah Selene Vlada she started looking
through blotters Hey yeah well that's
what happened when she was going through
the page because then she found more
photos of her husband nazar and so she
was like she posted also millions I did
did she come across her page like in the
in the feed like Xbox think it was the
Explorer she said that they have similar
oh that makes sense
cuz that's [ __ ] random yeah so then
she ended up commenting on their like
nice view from my husband's window look
about you on her page so this is the
couple this is Yulia and nazar oh she's
pretty
yeah both handsome
she's good model but now she's [ __ ]
pretty and they're both good-looking oh
it must be difficult to stay faithful if
you're good-looking I will never know
I wouldn't I will never know that
struggle what's it like huh yeah what's
it like to to like oh my god it's so
hard to not cheat because you're just
getting because there's so many options
you got it you're just like everywhere I
go it's like free candy so the husband
is art so she ended up confronting him
after she found photos of him on her
Instagram and so the husband denied that
anything was going on with her and she's
why does he deny when there's a [ __ ]
picture
so his explanation was that he invited
friends while she was away he invited
some friends over for a drink before
they went to the movies but then that's
it came for the Moscow mules but
Giulia's
don't oh and then he also added that
Vlada
is not his mistress that she was the
girlfriend of his friend so that's what
he told that's my other mistress honey
yeah that's when that's when Yulia was
like well if the guest its guests come
they would go to the kitchen for a drink
not the bedroom so she was like yeah
that's the [ __ ] thing so then just
move it she only had bet to sit on yeah
I'm glad I ended up closing her account
after she was confronted by the angry
wife and then but she she later openly
admitted on another social media
platform that she was sleeping with your
Leah's husband and that she was saying
like she was kind of like just laughing
at it's who she said quote she is his
wife not mine what's the problem is he
just a vegetable without free will don't
make me laugh and she started saying
that the critic like reading way to say
it I guess because it's translated is he
a vegetable without free will with the
carrot I don't understand what does he
donate Oh
what is he Boris soup I don't understand
you see just stupid beet stuck to the
ground you cannot walk everyone else is
living in the 18th century saying like
if I want to have sex I'll have it so
yeah but with married men I think even
in this century it's kind of a no-no you
could [ __ ] anybody she wants if everyone
single I think that that's there's no
one being hurt and or there was a prior
discussion of when we get married
please well do you want you know
everything is like well he has free will
I wanted a [ __ ] what's the problem
that's what she was a single chick so
then later the husband admitted or
acknowledged to having many lovers so he
was cheating on her with many other look
at how many photos of my bedrooms are
out there
wait wait why did so he got caught once
he was like fine like he just spilled
the beans on all I don't know exactly
the processes like how like why he
decided to admit or acknowledge other
lovers but he ended up acknowledging
them and but the funny thing is though
he said that he was never mentally
unfaithful to her
absolutely oh is it like that is it like
the argument where they're like I [ __ ]
them but I make love to you like what
does the other girl look like oh she's
not
blada she's pretty nice other girl talk
to you called it she's not as hot as the
other one though it's hard but it's a
different yeah it's like one is a club
hot the other one's girlfriend material
huh what looks like her [ __ ] stinks
what about the other one can we see can
we see the other girl for a second sure
what happened this is Julia how come she
looks different yeah why she looks so
different now what what did you do
because Russian what did you do ended up
going to a news station a new Russian
news of covering dishes so be weary but
unfuck see 11 News this man is like
about Putin and they just move that
aside to talk about this man this just
in North Korea
next girl's face transformed so many
times was Tina done I did look different
every single photo yeah it's a she was
she went to a news station with the
discoveries are like you know her
husband cheating on her all the time in
the fact that she found out through
Instagram and she was also saying that
she was contacting all these other women
that he had slept with and one of them
even cried on the phone to her saying
that she had no idea he was married cuz
heute the the husband was claiming that
every girl he cheated on you with that
he would tell them that he was married
but this one was like I never knew he
was married so much work to cheat that
many times dude this guy's a hard worker
man maybe it's not work if you're hot it
just comes to you oh yeah uh-huh
you could just [ __ ] fly around the
world like this and in people's mouths
online they just land on it and you just
all day you're like going down a [ __ ]
kumkum bear belt like just like this uh
and then there's like a [ __ ] line of
oh that's true maybe it's not a lot of
work for he's just
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]